[Music]
[Music]
sound is a massive components of any
horror experience and that's definitely
the case with alien we wanted to be as
authentic as possible when it came to
recreating the sound of the original
music and so we put together our own
Orchestra from the best musicians that
we knew around London including some who
had actually played on the original
recordings with Gerry back in the
nineteen seventies
[Music]
one of the most exciting aspects of
working on the sound for alien isolation
as they were given access to the
original sound recordings from the first
film five a section eight we were very
lucky because we were able to find some
very old recordings which showed the
process by which the sound design has
created a lot of those sounds and we
were able to recreate that process as
accurately as we could
[Music]
we have this really unpredictable clever
adaptive alien and we needed to build a
sound engine that could help support
that you couldn't just have a mixed look
static we needed a score that could
change and it could adapt based on what
the play is doing and based on what the
ADA was doing if the player is hiding
from the alien the sound engine will
know that and it will adapt it'll make
it more tense
the idea is to drive an emotional
reaction from the player in our game
sound is critical because when you're
hiding in the dog where you can hear
might just be the key to your survival
[Music]
you
[Music]